Một một nhanh chiến cơ quan từ bí hải quan và dí chủ mi ís,
đã tiến hành của với bắt lớn tại công trường xây dựng nhà máy pin,
pin, dài ảo gii, băng, cho chi nhà bắt sữa bốn chăm bầm lắm là đồng.
Để được xem là vụ bốn sáp tại nưu làm việc quý mô lớn nhất trong 2.5 qua.
Phần lớn là đồng hành cô đã bị đưa về nước,
sau nhiều là đồng gốc bị là tình vẫn mất kể chúng tình trạng pháp lý chưa gió sang.
Hến hành chăm ra đình dơ và khủ hành.
Các tổ chức sá hổ chờ biến, như chuyện nhỏ, phải xa dời chăm mẹ,
trong khi nhiều là đồng bị sâm dữ, dù có sế phép ở pháp,
xa viện này không chỉ tạo ra khủ sắp sá hội.
Mà có làm giấy lên lo ngài với mối trình đồ tư của Mỹ,
đối với các sân nghiệp nước ngoài.
Năm biến bột tình chiến tổng thống Mỹ đồ nơi trăm tình bố,
anh ngang là đậm nước ngoài.
Đồng thời các kết nỗ lực để sự cô tương tự không tài diễn.
Hó chính tình cũng để xuất đạm phản thị trường dành xin cho lâu đồng hành cô.
Năm dưới chỉ giống vỏ nội tưu chiến lực từ cô xa này.